حسنًا لنأخذ وجهة النظر من
الأرض سكوت أندرسون هو نائب
مدير أه الأونروا كما هي
معروفة في غزة ينضم إلي من رافا في
جنوب القطاع أه وشكراً على ذلك
بعض الحقائق التي
تخرج من غزة  الآن
تقشعر له الأبدان أه هذه التحذيرات من
انتشار مرض المجاعة أه جروح خطيرة لا
يتم علاجها أو عدم علاجها بشكل صحيح
ما هو الجانب الأكثر خطورة بالنسبة لك
عندما تنظر إلى غزة الآن
حسنًا، صباح الخير، شكرًا على إتاحة
الفرصة للتحدث معك اليوم.
يعني أعتقد أنه بالنسبة لنا هناك عدة
أشياء وكلها منقذة للحياة أه
الأول هو كما قلت
مستويات الجوع شديدة جدًا في
غزة أم ومن رفح إلى الشمال
يزداد الأمر سوءًا كلما اتجهت شمالًا أه
لذلك، فإننا نبذل جهودًا متضافرة
لمحاولة استيراد المزيد من المواد الغذائية إلى غزة
والتأكد من وصولها إلى الأشخاص المحتاجين،
بما في ذلك 1.4 مليون شخص في
محافظة رفح، وثانيًا،
تعرضت شبكة المستشفيات في غزة لأضرار
جسيمة أوشكت على الانهيار.  تبلغ
سعة الأسرة المنهارة أكثر من 300%
للأسرة العادية وأكثر من 200% لوحدة العناية المركزة،
وبسبب الوضع الأمني،
اضطرت منظمات مثل منظمة أطباء ساند فرونتيرز إلى إخلاء
المستشفيات حيث كانت تقدم
الدعم، لذلك يعد ذلك بمثابة إنقاذ للحياة إلى حد كبير بالنسبة لنا.
الوضع ومحاولة التأكد من
أننا نوصل الأشياء التي يحتاجها الناس
عندما تقول إسرائيل إن هجومها يمكن أن
يستمر لعدة أشهر أخرى. ما
يدور في ذهنك
جيدًا أعتقد أن الشيء الذي يدور في
ذهني سيكون صعبًا للغاية
على الأشخاص الذين هم  أعيش في الخيام
أعمل في مركز صحي في
جنوب غزة إذا نظرت إلى يساري من
النافذة ما أرى مدينة خيام أه
الناس يبذلون قصارى جهدهم ليعيشوا
حياتهم ويعتنوا بأطفالهم قدر
استطاعتهم  وقت الشتاء الآن في غزة لذلك
نحن دائما قلقون من التعرض
وخاصة للأطفال أه لكن
أكبر همني هو
الضغط على الناس بشكل غير عادي
ولا أعرف كم يمكنهم تحمل المزيد
قبل أن ينفجر شيء في
الجزء الجنوبي  من غزة بين
السكان المدنيين مما سيؤثر على
قدرة الأمم المتحدة وغيرها من المنظمات الإنسانية الدولية أه على الاستجابة
للعملية المستمرة على نطاق واسع
كما قلنا للتو لقد تم تهجير الغالبية العظمى من
سكان غزة البالغ عددهم 2.2 مليون نسمة،
أعني 90٪ وفقًا للأمم المتحدة
هذا أمر مذهل لقد زرت غزة
عدة مرات، إنه أمر ضئيل للغاية ما هي
الظروف بالنسبة لهؤلاء الأشخاص
خاصة مع هذه التقارير عن انتشار المرض،
أعني أن الظروف مزرية أه هي
الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكنني وصفها بها، لقد
أمضيت الكثير من الوقت في  غاز أيضًا هذا هو
الصراع الرابع الذي أخوضه والصراعات
الثلاثة الأخرى تتضاءل أمام
حجم وتأثير ما يحدث
اليوم كما تعلمون تحدثنا عن
قطاع الصحة والغذاء والشيء الآخر الذي
أود قوله  هذا يمثل
تحديًا كبيرًا بالنسبة للناس وهو الاغتسال، كما
تعلمون، يوجد في ملاجئنا ما يقرب من 300
شخص لكل حمام، لذلك في الغالب ما
يفعله الناس في حياتهم اليومية هو أنهم
يحاولون العثور على الطعام ويحاولون
البقاء دافئًا ويحاولون ذلك  ابحث عن
حمام، وهي كلها
أشياء بسيطة جدًا يمارسها معظمنا في
يومنا الطبيعي دون إعطاء
اعتبار ثانٍ للكيفية التي سنعرف بها
تحقيق
ذلك